[Musique]
travailler ensemble nouveau parlement
avec tous les partis nouvelle dynamique
dans cette chambre des communes
puisque le gouvernement de justin
trudeau est minoritaire
il aura besoin de l'appui de
l'opposition faire adopter ses projets
de loi
mais son défi ne se limite pas qu'à la
chambre des communes avec les
changements que justin trudeau apporter
ici au sénat les prochains mois pour
être compliqué pour lui en un sénat qui
est éclatée avec différents groupes
donc ça va être extrêmement difficile
pour lui de faire progresser sa
législation historique parce que vous
avez d'une part un sénat est dépendant
de plus en plus indépendants et d'autre
part le gouvernement minoritaire
mais cela dit fais pas dire que parce
que c'est unique
historiquement le sénat était formé de
deux groupes
les libéraux et les conservateurs cette
dynamique change toutefois dans la
foulée du scandale des dépenses au sénat
justin trudeau expulse les sénateurs
libéraux de son caucus afin dit il de
les rendre moins partisan de saleh de
spock
puis une fois premier ministre
il nomme des sénateurs indépendants
plusieurs d'entre eux forment nouveau
groupe qui devient majoritaire lors de
son premier mandat
le principal changement c'est
l'indépendance des sénateurs les
sénateurs n'ont plus à suivre une ligne
de parti ils sont libres d'esprit et
font ce qu'ils veulent plus
d'indépendance signifie plus de projet
de loi du gouvernement qui sont modifiés
au cours du premier mandat de justin
trudeau 30 projets de loi ont été
amendés contre un seul lors du dernier
mandat de stephen harper le sénat a
d'ailleurs est fière de ce bilan là
parce que le sénat peut dire ben voyons
on fait notre travail
il faut pas exagérer non plus grand
nombre d amendements qui ont été adopté
au sénat sur des amendements que le
gouvernement lui même à présenter
l'ancien sénateur andré pratte qui a
démissionné en octobre reproche au sénat
d'avoir une indépendance de façade
face à l'opposition conservatrice la
pression sur les sénateurs sénatrice
indépendante de voter avec le
gouvernement est très très forte
et souvent les sénateurs c'est la
possèdent à cette pression là nous
allons respecter la décision ultime de
la chambre des communes et du
gouvernement
pour la sénatrice indépendante raymonde
saint germain les sénateurs doivent
comprendre les limites de leur rôle à
moins et ce serait un cas de force
majeure qui nous semble que ce soit
tellement inconstitutionnelle que il
faille de cette manière là insisté et au
besoin d'en verser le gouvernement le
travail du gouvernement pour être encore
plus compliqué à l'automne
le sénat s'est à nouveau divisée
d'abord les sénateurs ont formé le
groupe des sénateurs canadiens afin dit
il de mieux représenter les régions
de leur côté les anciens libéraux ont
changé non ils sont devenus le groupe
des sénateurs progressistes mais quand
un des leurs a quitté le groupe il
n'était plus assez nombreux pour
conserver leur affiliation officiel
voici donc le plus récent portrait du
sénat les 51 sénateurs indépendants
forment le groupe le plus important
les conservateurs avec 24 sièges occupe
moins du quart du sénat les sénateurs
canadiens eux sont 13 et 12 n'ont aucune
affiliation
moi je pense qu'il risque à démultiplier
les groupes au sénat risque sur
l'efficacité mais il est certain que
jusqu'à maintenant la réforme de la
dépendance du sénat ne pas été complétée
au plan législatif plus que l'on soit
qu'il devra d'abord seynod le plus
fonctionnel possible qui joue son rôle
pour lequel il a été créé les libéraux
au premier en campagne électorale de
modifier la loi sur le parlement du
canada pour assurer la pérennité de
leurs réformes
sinon rien n'empêcherait futur premier
ministre de faire marche arrière et
nommer des sénateurs ouvertement
partisan
il siffle vincent foisy radio canada
ottawa